what we're going to do in this video is
dig a little bit deeper into labor
markets and where it's really not going
to be any fundamentally new concepts
we're really just going to reapply
concepts that we've already seen before
and maybe use slightly different words
but the reason why labor is interesting
is labor is one of the factors of
production it's one of the inputs you
need for firms to produce whatever they
do produce and unlike most in most
markets if we're talking about the
computer markets let me write over here
in the computer market in the computer
market the demand the demand is coming
from individuals so it's coming from
I'll just call it individual people
while the supply is coming from firms is
coming from firms in the labor market
it's the other way around
in the labor market the demand is coming
from firms these are the people who need
labor who are hiring the labor so this
is coming from firms and the supply is
coming from individual people so it's
coming from individual individual people
and what's interesting about that is
because the demand is coming from firms
in the past we went when the supply was
coming from firms we could look at a
firm's cost structure and we could come
up with a supply curve from that now
that the demand is coming from firms we
could look at a firm's essentially their
revenue structure how much incremental
revenue do they get per extra employee
and we can actually generate a demand
curve their marginal benefit curve by
looking at their business a little bit
closer and that's essentially what we're
going to be doing in this video and
these aren't any fundamentally new ideas
we're just applying them in a slightly
different way and we'll use slightly
different words now let's assume for the
sake of this video that I run a car wash
a car wash and it is a competitive car
wash it is a competitive car wash I have
to be a price taker I do not have a
monopoly or oligopoly I'm not even a
monopolistic competitor
there are many car washes in the city we
are undifferentiated we are all offering
the same surface and so I'm going to be
a price taker and let's say the
equilibrium price and this market for
competitive car washes is five dollars
per car wash
five dollars per car wash and just as a
little bit of review that it also means
remember I this is a competitive firm
not a monopoly that my marginal revenue
is equal to a constant five dollars per
car wash if I do one car wash I'll get
five dollars to car washes ten dollars
three car washes fifteen dollars in the
monopoly the marginal revenue would
change so let's think about how how much
benefit I would get from each
incremental employee so first I will do
a so let's make this column right over
here let's take this L for labor so this
is going to be the quantity of labor and
I'm going to think what I hire what zero
people one two three four or five people
and then let's say and let's think about
how much that we can produce when I hire
these amounts of people so I'll call
that I'll call that total product or we
could call that total product of labor
it's essentially saying what how many
cars can I wash this is going to be car
washes per hour so cars cars washed
washed per hour how many cars can I wash
per hour with a different number of
people here well if I have zero people
I'm going to wash the zero cars let's
say I find if I have one person that
that person can wash five cars per hour
by him or herself two people can wash
nine cars together three people can do
twelve cars four people can do 14 and
five people can do fifteen 15 cars
together and we can plot this let's
lecture you plot this on a graph just to
see what's going on it always helps to
visualize things so let me so that is
going to be our total product that is
going to be our total product and this
is going to be our quantity of labor and
the quantity of labor we can have one
two three four or five people this is
actually zero people right over here and
my total product goes all the way up to
fifteen so let's say that this is
fifteen this would be ten and this would
be five 5 10 and 15 and so we can plot
these points right over here what is the
total product well this is zero zero
zero people I'm not watching
any cars per our total product is in
cars wash per hour if I if I have one
person one person I can wash five cars
per hour if I have two people I can wash
nine cars per hour two people I can wash
nine cars per hour three people I can
wash twelve cars per hour three people I
can wash twelve cars it's about right
there four people I can wash 14 cars per
hour
four people 14s right about there and
then finally I will do this in well the
see I'm already using a lot of my colors
listen pink five people I can wash 15
cars per hour five people I can wash 15
cars per hour and so total product as a
function of quantity of Labor will look
like a curve that looks something like
this I could just connect the dots or I
could make it look a little bit more
curvy so it's going to look something
it's going to look something like that
and so one way that we should think
about it in as you'll see in economics
when you always want to think about how
much you want to produce or how much you
want to hire you always want to think
about how much benefit are you getting
for that incremental thing when you're
when you're thinking about your cost
structure how much cost for that
incremental unit when you think about
when you're thinking about your benefits
or your demand you're saying how much
benefit am I getting from that
incremental unit so let's view this as
the marginal let's write marginal
product MP sometimes in some economics
textbooks I've seen this referred to as
MPL marginal product of labor actually
I'll just write the L there to make it
clear this is the marginal product of
labor so when we go from zero people to
one person on average between those two
points over there we're able to our
Delta R change Delta is just the Greek
letter that symbolizes change our change
in total product is five and so we can
view that as the average the average
marginal product or you can kind of say
that is the marginal project halfway
between these or you could view that as
the marginal average marginal product
between those two points right over
there that's why I wrote it in a row
that is in between these two points it's
taking us from zero to one and actually
let me plot these while I draw them
while I calculate what they are so I'll
draw this one a
little bit more a little bit more flat
so I have space which I could scroll
down a little bit so in this axis I'm
going to do marginal product of labor
and then on this axis I'm going to have
the quantity of labor so this is 1 this
is 2 this is 3 4 people and 5 people so
this point right over here
this point right over here that's the
marginal product of labor halfway you
could view this as the slope halfway
between 0 and 1 or you could view this
as the average slope from 0 to 1 so I'll
plot it right over here
I'll view it and actually I label these
axes so this is let's call this 5 4 3 2
1 so halfway between 0 and 1 my marginal
product of labor is 5 right over there
then halfway between 1 and 2 my marginal
product of labor I go from 5 cars washed
per hour to 9 so my marginal product of
labor is 4 so between 1 & 2 my marginal
product of labor is 4 and then between 2
& 3 between 2 & 3 my marginal product
labor I go from 9 car washes cars washed
per hour to 12 so I have 3 incremental
cars washed by adding that third person
so the average you could view it as the
slope right over there is going to be 3
so the slope right over there is going
to be 3 I didn't make this completely to
scale and then these are a little bit
but more bunched up down here but let's
just keep going
then from going from 3 to 4 the marginal
product of labor I will go from 12 cars
washed brook to 14 so I get two extra
cars washed by adding that fourth person
so between 3 & 4 I get an incremental on
average to two cars for that extra
person and then finally between 4 & 5 I
get one extra car so between 4 & 5 I get
exactly one extra car and so I'm going
to get and it looks like a little bit
like a curve here because I bunched up
the measurements but this really should
be a line this really should be this
really should be a line I mean
I mean well that's my best I don't want
to have to reap lot all the points but
this should be a line like that every
time we went every time we moved up one
we went down we went down one every time
we moved up one we moved down one we see
that over here when we went we went to
five four three two one so this is five
four three two one so this really should
be a straight line so this is
essentially plotting the slope of this
curve at any point now what we can think
about is because this is this by itself
this is telling us the marginal benefit
in terms of cars washed but this doesn't
tell us the marginal benefit in terms of
dollars and to do that we need the
marginal product revenue or you could
call it the value of the marginal
product of labor and so let me write
that over here so we could call this the
NPR NPR for marginal product revenue or
we could view that as the value of the
marginal product of labor but
essentially we're just saying okay if
we're watching five extra cars from that
first person and I'm going to get five
dollars per car wash I have a I have a
constant marginal revenue I am a price
taker then I'm going to make twenty five
dollars on those incremental five cars
and if I wash four more cars I'm going
to four times five I'm going to make
twenty extra dollars if I wash three
extra cars I'm going to make fifteen
extra dollars two extra cars ten extra
dollars I'm just multiplying by five
every time this is times five times five
times five times five and I wash one
extra car times five dollars per car I'm
going to make five extra dollars and so
essentially we could take every point on
this curve and we could multiply it by
five to get our marginal product of
revenue or marginal product revenue to
be careful where I say the of let me
plot that and I'll try to plot that a
little bit neater so it's clear that
this is a line so let me that's my
marginal product revenue you could also
view that as the marginal benefit
calculated in terms of dollars you could
view this as a marginal benefit in terms
of cars washed this is the marginal
benefit in terms of dollars and right
over here we're gonna have the quantity
of labor so one two
three actually I want them to line up a
little bit better
so one is right over there two is right
over there
three is there four is there five is
there one two three four five I'm just
cool down a little bit this is my
quantity of labour and the marginal
product revenue goes up to twenty five
so let's say this is five 10 15 20 and
25 and so is halfway between zero and
one person so this is 25 right over here
I am producing 25 dollars or I get an
incremental revenue of 25 dollars half
way on average you can view this point
right over here multiply it by five I'm
getting to 25 dollars on average for
that incremental person then when we go
to this point right over here we're
getting 20 dollars we're getting 20
dollars that's this right over there
then when we go to this point in orange
if we multiply it times 5 we get 15
dollars so this is 5 10 15 so that's
halfway between 2 and 3 our marginal
product revenue is $15 so that is make
it clear this is 15 right over there and
then halfway between 3 and 4 people it's
$10 halfway between 3 & 4 it is $10 so
it's going to look something like this
and then halfway between finally between
4 & 5 it is $5 it is $5 and so we're
just picking points along here we pick
kind of the midpoint the slope at those
points or the average slope between 0 &
1 but this is if you assume this curve
has a continuous slope that the slope
changes continuously then this will be a
line and then this will be a line as
well so our line would look something
like that and what's neat about this
line is essentially this is the marginal
benefit curve marginal benefit curve for
this firm as it as it gets more and more
labor so it's essentially the demand
curve for this firm and if you wanted to
find the demand curve for the market you
could just take the demand curve for
each of these competitive firms and then
you would just add them all together